On paper. If I were to show the 14 year
old version of me what I had
accomplished, if I could go back in
time and be like, Bro, look what you
just did. The 14 year old version of me
would be like. Like what?
Like, I knew it, you know what I mean?
But the actual, you know, at that time,
28 year old version of 29 year old
version was not feeling like a was not
feeling good. You know what I mean?
It was not feeling it wasn't enough
appreciation. It wasn't enough like a
recognition of what I was actually
doing. It was too much emphasis and
focus on where I wasn't yet, and that
hadn't been me up until that point.
So that sparked it probably was like a
couple years.
Is that you you're saying like the, the
focus on what you were doing, the
emphasis from the outside is that you
putting pressure on yourself. Is that
you not being happy with not hearing
certain things about the work you're
doing? 100%. That was it.
It was ego driven 100%.
It was like there was a nugget somebody
dropped from me. They didn't know what
I was going through necessarily, but
maybe they maybe they saw something.
But it it sparked it sparked a practice
that would lead me to exactly what you
started a conversation with, which was
like just a more, like, peaceful place
in my life and more of a you know what
I mean? And that was a at the time I
had and at this time it's it's the
team. My team ain't right, you know
what I mean? At that time when it's ego
driven, like and you're not getting the
things you want. And at this time, for
me, it was like, Oh, the Grammys, they
ain't not f***ing me. Oh, the the such
and such magazine or this one.
Why I'm not in the why I'm not up here.
You know what I mean? This is quietly
what was happening in my mind.
So I got with this new publicist,
Kathryn Frazier, and she's amazing
woman And, and and, you know, in the
midst of us talking, we would have
conversations outside of, like, just
career and she would just telling me
how she was into meditation.
She was into like transcendental
meditation and boom.
And I had flirted with it like in my
early 20s like practice it a little
bit, just didn't really know what I was
doing, but had a nice little
experience. But I didn't dive into it.
But mind you, her telling me about that
was coinciding with me realizing, Yo,
something's going on, bro. You got it.
You got it. So, So I had set rules for
myself. One was like, Bro, you can't go
on social media no more like we're from
the first generation of, like,
entertainers, celebrities, whatever,
where it's like, bro, you could
literally at any minute see what
somebody's saying about you, you know
what I mean? And it's like there was
nobody to tell you, like cigarettes
when the whole world for decades was
smoking cigarettes. There wasn't a
there wasn't anybody loudly saying
like, oh, that's that's going to kill
you in about You probably shouldn't do
that. It took a long time for somebody
to to realize how harmful this was.
And similarly, we're in we're in a
generation where our entertainers, our
basketball players, our boom boom boom,
like no one was there.
And even now, nobody's there to be
like, don't Google yourself.
Don't don't search your name on boom,
boom, boom. So I say all that to say I
had set some rules for myself, some
baseline rules like, Yo, don't don't go
on Twitter, don't read your replies, do
not search your name. Boom, boom, boom.
That's rule number one. Number two,
when you're creating, you got to create
from a pure place only like there was a
rule I set for myself. Like everything
has to only be truly what you feel in
your heart.
Of course, coming because you saw you
saw yourself do the opposite.
You saw yourself. You saw yourself dive
deep into the space of social media.
I'm searching. I see what they're
saying. I'm getting angry.
I'm getting irritated. Yeah.
Yeah. How the f***? What the f***?
Okay, now I'm creating and my creative
from. Yes, bro. This is infused hundred
percent and influencing my creative
b****. I see what you said.
Like it's now becoming a part--
The nastiest place to ever do some art,
artful shit and some and some pure.
It's just like, Yo, you can't.
It's like you have to leave all room.
I feel like in the creative process for
like for God, you know what I mean?
And the minute you start, like thinking
about what somebody else is going to
think about it, boom, boom, boom.
I caught myself in that space for a
moment and it was so unfamiliar to me
because that's never how I used to
work. And it was.
And so to get up out of that, I had set
these.
Ground rules struggle, though.
Was it was it an easy transition?
It was easy. Was it a battle?
No, it was it was.
I mean, I'm not going to say it was
like because you realize those things
are addictions, right? Those things
become addictions like like social
media becomes an addiction. So, yeah,
in a sense, it's like you have to you
have to check yourself and tell
yourself like, don't do that.
You know what I mean? Like, or catch
yourself. Now get off of there.
But every time you every time I feel
like. Every time you say no, like while
battling like an addiction, it's like
you get stronger. You add a pebble to
your, like, to your strength.
You know what I mean? So, like, I like
that. You know what I mean? It's like,
yo, the A no is a powerful thing and
you get stronger and the other thing
gets just a little more weaker.
So, so but, so while I set these ground
rules for myself, she mentioned the
meditation and she had explained to me
like how her experience with it and
like how life change it was and how
clear she felt. And so I was like, you
know what? I was out in LA.
Like I had came out here to work on the
album. I had the album titled 2014
Forest Hills Drive. I had it all mapped
out. I knew what the album's going to
be called. I knew was going to buy the
house back. It all felt like it was
like supposed to happen.
And and I started adding that by the
time five months hit, I would have
these revelations and clarity about my
life, and I would see what was actually
happening in my life and where I was
headed. You know what I mean?